each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
alright everybody I'd like to welcome
Larry vada to Microsoft to give a talk
today about productivity in scientific
computing Larry is a consultant for
software fault tolerance and
productivity he has a bachelor's from
university of maryland college park and
PhD from MIT in physics and lighter
worked for Bell Labs for about 20 years
10 years working on real-time software
development and about 10 years working
on software engineering research he
worked in the Peter Weinberger's lab
there and then he retired in the 1999
and then went to work for sun
microsystems working on high-performance
super computing systems and worked on
one of sons entries to the DARPA
supercomputing project in the last
couple years he's authored more than 60
papers and several chapters in books on
software engineering so like you to
welcome liye Radha okay thank you Andy
okay um a little bit of historical
perspective here the back in about
ninety nine the Japanese brought online
what was called the earth simulator as a
significant technological event to
highlight their maturity and being able
to build supercomputers and also to
highlight a little bit the the second
millennium coming of age about being
able to model the climate changes that
that are suspected to be induced by
human activity and it was called the
earth simulator and if sent a shock wave
actually through the Department of
Defense and through the weapons industry
in the United States because of the fact
that it will it it claimed the lead and
supercomputers and that charged off
several people in the
darpa which is the DoD's research
programs community to start thinking
about what was going on and what had
happened and this also followed if
people had not been to Jemaine so I'm
going to give a little bit of historical
thing and then I'll get into the remarks
about my talk which is understanding the
productivity gridlock in scientific
computing the 90s were very very
tumultuous for high performance
computing people were building a lot of
clusters and having a lot of trouble
programming them there was some major
failures of programs the physicist
community for instance undertook a
tremendously ambitious program to be
able to fully simulate nuclear weapons
okay and that was called the ASCII
program maybe a lot of people didn't see
it but it did affect everybody because
it was part of the ending of the Cold
War in the sense that all nuclear tests
or the nuclear test ban treaty started
in 91 and the reason the US even signed
up to it was because physicists said
they didn't need the buck blow up
anymore they could basically blow them
up in computers and of course that was a
bit of wishful thinking and the 90s came
and went and found us still struggling
computationally to even be able to
simulate reasonably tokamak fusion
machines and things that would even have
some societal value although ending the
Cold War certainly had a lot of value to
society in any case the DoD going back
to this three people Bob gray bill bill
carlson and and John groche sent a
letter to Congress basically out of the
Department of Defense saying we're in a
lot of trouble actually Bob graybill was
a dark the program manager John Groce
was DoD one of the computing resource
people and bill carlson was a
three-letter agency top computer
architect and the they said basically we
have a crisis we have a crisis because
they saw
all these programs failing you will
actually see where some of all or all
this is coming from I and so they
basically convinced Congress to actually
fund what is called the high
productivity computing system which was
supposed to be the next generation super
computer system that would in essence
create a leap frog in the ability for
scientists and engineers to use the
machine to accomplish or add value or
work Akane it's called high productivity
computing systems or hpcs the program is
in phase three now there are two vendors
doing it at Cray and IBM son was in part
of phase two there were six that were
down selected to 3 and phase 2 and then
2 and phase 3 phase one was from 2001 to
2003 2003 to 2006 and in 2006 to 2011
and those are rough dates by the way
that's not exactly there's never nothing
ever falls exactly on December 31st
anyway the or January first whichever
you know it depends which side of the
interval you want to go on anyway the
needless to say son did not make meet
phase 3 but I think we learned a lot and
I was very fortunate to be one of the
principal investigators in that program
and I actually I also have the advantage
that I was one of the few vendors lead p
is that was also a computational
scientists than a former life I actually
wrote one of the first computational
fluid dynamic programs at MIT as a
high-energy physicist actually I was
modeling a neutrino detector which I
really wanted to build and at the time
of 1971 seemed to me to be the very
modest price of 10 million dollars and
it would have been stuck out at Fermilab
about two miles from the accelerator
because you need a lot of Earth to
remove everything except the neutrinos
out of the beam and of course the beam
then goes through West Chicago and a few
other places but neutrinos go through
everything
we don't have any problem with that
anyway the so I had a lot of fun doing
that I also ended up doing some other
computational theoretical work but so it
was very a very very unique position for
me and actually seduced me to stay at
Sun Microsystems they actually go do
this but in the end where I came out was
that people talked about productivity
crisis they talked about productivity
gridlock is my word for it and it's
because like any interdependent system
of workflow anybody who study project
management for anything of significance
like any of the major operating systems
or office or five ESS switching software
any of these things are a huge set of
interdependent relationships among
people and machines doing things and
anybody who understands those things
understands that their bottlenecks do
occur okay and gridlock does happen even
when every everyone and all entities
involved have have a very very the right
priorities and everything and so in some
sense this is a little bit of that story
as well I will also say this is kind of
an interesting story for Microsoft as it
was for lucent technologies and eighteen
t bell telephone laboratories and Bell
Labs in that I think one of the most
interesting problems to understand as we
move forward because of where the wealth
in our society has been captured and how
it is actually provided to all members
of the society is how to maintain and
evolve large legacy software systems and
so part of this story is about that as
well okay because what you're going to
see is the value of these things is
really in the fact that i can
computationally do things rather than
build them and once i can cut in and
what i need to be able to do then is
saying is say with some certainty that
the computational results represent what
would happen in the real world so any
case let me go through my remarks and
then we can chat about a lot of
different things and andy was very very
kind and actually setting me up with a
calendar for today and hopefully I'll
get a chance to talk with people later
on it should be a lot of fun so so I'm
always a believer that the answer is yes
well of course it's yes the
computational scientists need to realize
that the greatest strengths maybe the
greatest barriers to improvement they've
they were able to take some of the
earliest machines and come up with some
very very great results and of course
they did some extraordinary things to be
able to get enough computation there in
the first place I I'm often i'll tell
you a one little story about this is
that um i remember i told you about that
simulation i had written and so i was
working for a high-energy physics group
called the kendall rosen ssin and
friedman group and Henry Kendall and
Jerry Friedman our Nobel Prize winners
in physics and I asked Henry Kendall who
was at who had started his career as a
computational high-energy physicist what
did he do and this is of course working
back in one of the first machines that
he wouldn't tell me what it was because
he wasn't sure it was the class of ideas
yet but he had talked to von Neumann and
everything and had actually been working
as a graduate student with one of the
people at Los Alamos and things and he
eventually admitted to me that he had
numerically inverted a 5 by 5 matrix to
do some perturbation theory calculation
this is of course 1952 all right but it
gives you an idea yeah that's that's
like I mean you could do that on you
could have done that on a vax 11 780
with your eyes closed in in nineteen
eighty or with even probably a
radioshack trash 80 probably if you just
made sure that you had the
floating-point arithmetic correct on
that I never remembered if that had the
right floating-point arithmetic not but
any case the the idea is is that what
that what but what computational
scientists have done is they've grown up
with the computer industry is they've
actually worked on bare metal a lot of
times and they've actually done more
tricks and more things than you would
ever want to really as a software
engineer even want to look at on the
other hand software engineers new
realize that past success is soft
similar but not identical problems
confronting the computational scientists
and there are for certain solutions may
need to be reevaluated and reformulated
I mean that seems to be
you routed that the cost benefits are
different in the computational world
than they are in the business world and
in the automation of supply chains
marketing all the management of
information that we use to actually make
our economy more efficient and that's a
different problem than what's
confronting the computational scientist
or design engineer as they use their
tools okay so I'm going to talk about
motivation the productivity problem this
is really kind of fascinating what is it
the communication gap between scientific
programmers and software engineers a
sidebar I'm going to give a little meth
illogic sidebar and I actually stuck
this in because Andy and I have been
talking over the last six weeks or salad
and one of the the contributions I think
of the of our group to the hpcs
community has been to bring about a
credibility in our studies of how do we
really study computational scientists
and how do we extract what they're doing
in a way that allows us to be scientist
in a qualitative and quantitative sense
how do you actually manage that
information and in essence reduce it
down to some set of models that are
predictive and allow you to understand
what you're doing and in design and in
in the building of these systems I'm
going to talk a little bit about the
expertise gap I'll actually see if I can
manage to burn out somebody's retina the
expertise gap and one of the most
significant things this turns out to be
the subject of a 2005 physical tix today
article I wrote with Doug post who was
one of the computational physicists that
I met during the doing this DARPA high
productivity computing system program
that the problem is is that it's exactly
like what it wasn't five ESS after I got
through all the terminology and
everything else which is every time you
make a change in a computational code
you don't know if you broke something
put a different way how do I trust the
results okay and so and anybody who's
ever worked on change management and
configuration management
stones and I you know I know several
people at Microsoft Research spent
several tenure set spent some time at at
bell labs and everything else and we
used to have it we had tremendous
configuration management systems and we
could tell what was changed and so on
and so forth the reality though is is
you don't know if you ever broke broke
it once you've made a change and that's
actually a significant problem so how
about breaking the productivity gridlock
one of the characteristics of the
research I like to do is I like to have
empiricism embedded in it so not only do
you do observational studies to see what
is happening nor experiments to identify
mechanism so you can build theories and
and therefore end up predicting I also
like to do experimental studies to see
if the ideas that I have or that my team
has actually work in general in Envy in
vitro initially in other words in a
laboratory does it really work and then
in vivo if if you if it in life meaning
put these back into a team of physicists
doing the next generation of weather
forecasting models or whatever and
seeing if it really does improve their
productivity and stuff and finally some
colluding concluding remarks and then
I'm going to talk about mentioned my
collaborators because there are many and
they're fun and then for those
insomniacs in the audience I have a
bibliography and they can certainly go
at it I'm only going to go highlighting
through some of these and feel free to
ask me questions at any time either live
or in ether space there and we'll try to
address them in real time ok so I don't
think I need in this audience to talk
about motivations for why
high-performance computing is a big deal
I will recognize that some of the things
that I mentioned the people in the
general population and they don't even
think about it until you talk about it
is if you look at the per cap the number
of people on our highways and the number
of traffic deaths it's going down and a
lot of its
cause of social policies around dealing
with people in driving under the
influence of alcohol others are better
safety laws and so on and so forth and
methods to operate a car but another
whole set of things is that to be
perfectly honest crashes still happen
and not as many people die and auto
crash models are a big a big part of
that and we don't have to crash them in
the walls anymore every automobile
manufacturer napkin can sit there and
model and run through ten thousandth
crash sequences of different
configurations in different
intersections under different weather
conditions and get some idea about how
to tune and move safety features around
in the car to actually provide the
highest probability of survival another
one which I found is very interesting is
procter gamble packaging this is when
they get sold but Congress a lot which I
find it used to be anybody knows the
press potato chips the Frankel's that
people make crinkles that's it that's it
crinkles so anyway their production what
happened what was happening is that they
were flying off the conveyor belt as
they were being baked and everything so
what they did was they changed the shape
to reduce the lift so they can run it
faster and actually produce more
crinkles per minute off the assembly
line I these are neat things but it's a
computational fluid dynamics problem and
they just had too much lift in them and
the crinkle okay but I mean the reason I
mentioned it is not all these
computational things have to be you know
my gosh kind of you know big whiz-bang
things saving people's lives but
everyone has a little bit of interest
that wedding weather modeling and
prediction is obviously one and one that
people didn't really recognize and and
actually I know Motorola spent tens of
millions of dollars renting
supercomputers was to actually do
cellphone layouts and the unit of
initial networks and of course there
were different techniques for doing that
and all kinds of things it but it's a
science unto itself trust me when you
have scattering of electromagnetic
radiation off of water towers and hills
and iron deposits in those hills things
get interesting real quick I don't know
how many people are aware that that
there's a whole set of experiments
continually being done on you every time
you walk into a costco and market
walmart okay they put stuff in certain
places to see if they can make it see if
they can how is it with me i want to say
i don't want to sound too cynical make
it easy for you to buy it i guess is the
right thing and and so they actually
talk about yielded per square foot in
certain parts of the store and
everything I've I find it very very
fascinating but literally when I was
doing some of this phase two computer
stuff obviously darpo is always
concerned about looking for commercial
applications and one set that I wasn't
even aware of was the just the real-time
capture of information at all the
walmart stores or walgreens stores or
costco stores and figuring out and
redistributing their their inventories
and so that's one set of problems and
other set of problems is just how do i
what what where is the right place to
put some of these things what do people
buy when they only by three things are
only stopping for five minutes versus
stopping for a half an hour and buying
ten thing and there's all these kind of
thing obviously the pics are and stuff
like that entertainment motion picture
industry one that i ran into last night
which was a lot of fun is and I've had
to put that in with swimsuit design did
anybody see MVC evening news last night
so and I used to be a swimmer so in my
high school life and one of the things
that's very very interesting is this
year and the before the Olympics
everybody goes and do the trials and
swimmers are using the last ones to do
there who's going to be on the Olympic
swimming teams kind of thing and it
turns out that that if you look at the
number of World Records broken it's like
dramatic and it turns out that nASA has
been working with the elite swimmers in
the United States and they've designed
suits that actually reduce the drag drag
so significantly that more World Records
have been broken in the last you know
trials of the last three weeks then
has ever been seen in the sport before
and people are now get wondering what's
going on kind of thing and it's not
broken by two hundredths of a second
kind of broken it's being broken these
are world records being broken by a
second and a half in a 45 second I
probably my guess is they probably well
but I mean you know speedo is guess you
know a speedo is the one it but I mean I
only point it out because what what this
is kind of it you know hey if you've
gotta swim fast away from the shark it
might be a real useful thing to have a
speedo suit on you no answer any case so
what is the productivity problem well
you know this is this is a slide that
was put up by the DARPA program managers
and everything and I kind of it it's
visually stunning it sort of captures
some of the information that G today we
have a one hundred to a thousand
processors and the future is 10 to 100 k
and it really does feel like if you've
ever done any of these computations it
really does feel like I'm not sure if a
dragon is sitting over the cliff I
usually think more of a snake coming up
and biting me kind of thing and tripping
me up whenever I thought I could do one
of these things but in any case it the
point of this picture is that this is
one visualization that I think plays
well to a non technical audience but
really doesn't help you at all
understand what the real problem is ok
yeah we don't have dragons sitting you
know on the other side of precipices and
as we as naive software engineers or
walking off the bridge right into the
dragon's mouth kind of thing it's that's
not what it really is or computational
scientist so that's why i put it up by
the way just to be a little bit humorous
but let's go back so here's a kind of an
interesting another approach to
productivity problems is first principle
kind of thing right to being a physicist
i'm a first principle kind of person you
can't take the physicist out of the
person you know i'm sorry the
productivity is equal to the utility
over the cost this is this thing
the economic definition and it's
conceptually a great idea of value per
unit cost increases per capita wealth
increases the only problem is is that
things always get renormalized okay
inflation you know 1971 dollars or a lot
different than two thousand and eight
dollars and definition of value I mean
there are technologies are grown up just
in the last 50 years it completely
evaluate and invalidate any of the value
propositions of organizations in the way
things were done in the 50s and 60s so
the bottom line is is that it's a it's
always a continuous leary normalizable
kind of relative ratio measure and what
does it mean for computational science
which we kind of a good question so and
and so from from these first two slides
what I'm trying to motivate is that you
know the first thing that really we have
to do is we really have to get
underneath the hood and figure out to
push the metaphor of an automobile that
to figure out really what the problem is
and so we're going to do that a little
bit i'm going to sketch out how we went
through some of this okay so if you come
at it from exactly the computational
scientist review point this is what is
sorry about that for people online there
I think I was moving my beard around the
first is that if you look at the problem
you have a performance challenge
designing and building high-performance
computers is a hard thing to do you have
a programming challenge you have a lot
of these you have you want to do rapid
code development if you're doing
application development like for
instance either investigating new
science or building new application
programs for doing new kinds of
computations if the optimized these
codes for good performance and then you
have the prediction challenge developing
predictive codes with complex science
scientific models developed codes that
are reliable and predictive capability
now the problem is is that i can tell
you right now that in five ESS any major
release of five ESS software over fifty
percent was spent over fifty percent of
the effort was spent
and verification and validation okay all
right just to give you an idea in other
words did it did it work all the time
was it did it was the system designed
with doing what it was designed to do
the computational science depending on
the domain I'm n has you know different
types of cost benefits for instance one
of the biggest growth industries I think
of besides entertainment which i think
is one where a high-performance
computing is really getting into and
really making headways and and I put
that cut it is is what I call
computational medicine where you're
actually your genome some genomic marker
information of what types of proteins
are being expressed when your DNA is
actually inputted into some set of
computational models that allow you for
instance then to actually adjust
treatment and you're starting to see
some of this and some of the big and
this is really interesting for people
who want to read about this I'm not sure
there's a book out about it yet but you
know the war on cancer has been a very
interesting kind of thing because their
people wanted to cure cancer and it
turns out to be sort of similar to a lot
of other problems well it's great
conceptual goal the problem is we don't
even know what cancer is so curious it's
kind of a hard thing so in the last 40
years President Nixon and 71 was it you
know maybe 40 years ago almost now you
know declared the war on cancer and it
was a great war but unfortunately we
didn't have the science there yet to
understand what was going on and only
now but bottom line there the
verification and validation is going to
be kind of important and actually you'll
see we actually went in and studied a
computational biochemist to to see how
they would rewrite an amber code amber
code is an electrostatic potential code
of complex proteins the bioactivity of a
protein is dependent on how it folds in
a three-dimensional space when it's an
equilibrium with a radiation field and
actually it's not one shape but it's
many shapes and the reality is is you
need to have of yet need to do an
optimization
problem because the principle of least
action sort of indicates that the shapes
that it will fold into our minimum
electrostatic potential configurations
okay and we were actually working with
one of the top people writing that
particular code but that's sort of the
basic science that has to be done before
you can start writing an application
that might simulate and then of course
eventually get to this vision of a
computational medicine kind of thing it
also highlights the kind of problem and
evolution you're looking at at any given
time when you go in and look at the high
performance computing community is that
I don't think there's any problem where
there are multiple scales involved in
both time and space where things are
approximated by one of my collaborators
Doug post tells a really interesting
story about being around he was he
worked at Los Alamos and Etta lawrence
livermore and he was talking about the
they would have a computational science
meeting once a week and they would be
simulating how nuclear weapons worked
and everything this is back in the 50s
and edward teller was was one of the
physicist who was doing that and it was
for many many years the director and
edward teller has a lot of history in
this whole arena but one of the
interesting things that that happens and
what is and that you see even in the 50s
and they realize this is that you
couldn't do the computation exactly and
so what you were always doing was
finding good approximations and the
story that's told by one of my friends
is is that he was a young graduate
student up there for the first time
trying to defend this set of
approximations and edward tellers in the
back of Norman says approximation has no
physics throw it out of the code yeah
and and but the problem is is it seemed
to work because what they had done is
they had experimentally verified it
which you know brings about a lot of
interesting questions about verification
and validation so so I talked about it
from the scientist point of view but
what does it really mean I mean I just
put up those three things and yeah we
have this continuously changing set of
platforms we have the continual
continually evolving and maintained
code base and everything the reality is
the sim some of the symptoms are saying
a long and troubled software
developments you're seeing dysfunctional
markets to support tools you're seeing
scientific results based on software
sometimes not always correct in fact
some of these have been tremendously
tragic tanned and gosh knows how much is
really going to end up causing the
costing the US economy at some point
scientific programmers have some
interesting views computer scientists
don't address our needs there isn't
enough money and really as we understood
and started studying this community we
we understood a couple of things so we
actually and you'll see my sidebar in a
minute which is kind of interesting how
we study this kind of thing but what we
ended up observing was a communication
gap and so let me talk about the
communication yet yep oh okay so Tom's
question is what the scientific results
based on software if I can if I ok I'm
on slide 9 so let me go and I'll show
you exactly that ok yes the scientific
results based on software is is the ram
is the problem of the verification and
validation ok in other words what
happens you have a code that tells you
this this and this and you go out in
nature and that's the way this this is
this turns out to be so codes correct it
then makes another prediction isn't
correct ok however what what happens in
scientific results based on software is
that it not only becomes a tool for an
engineer to use it also is a tool for
scientists to use to figure out what the
laws of nature are ok and sometimes
you're wrong ok and you know a lot of
times like in experimental methodologies
we have hypothesis tests and we say okay
we have a confidence level and so we set
up a basically a statistical game and
then we can probabilistic alee reason
about whether we can reject the null
hypothesis and so on and so forth ok
it's just a fact number two is okay the
symptoms of the productivity crisis are
it it's basically the worst case in
productivity is you get the wrong answer
because no work actually got done and
zero value got at it right so the
numerator wrong result correct incorrect
result right got it yeah sorry that's
good point yeah ah okay so that by the
way at the end of this talk for those
people who have access to the PDF online
and here I out two cases of exactly that
one is a plasma physics result that was
widely believed that stopped the United
States from entering into the ITER
program which is the international
collaboration to build a demonstration
fusion toroid power generation device
okay and the second one was the
challenger shuttle had a program called
crater which looked at the impact of
micrometeorites on the heat shields of
the of the space shuttle wing leading
edges and made certain predictions and
of course we know that one was a
very tragic that crater indicated that
there wasn't going to be a problem for
the Challenger to come back down and so
consequently nobody ever thought well
what if what if the computation is wrong
because the computation had always been
correct up until that point says tragic
at many different levels so let me talk
about the communication gap to culture
it two cultures separated by a common
language it's kind of interesting and in
fact this one of the one of my
collaborators is a is a cultural
anthropologist and and she loves that
which he gives us thought she doesn't
much better than I do and what she talks
about is the you have these people who
speak the same language and can't figure
out why they aren't communicating and
it's exactly you know the software
engineer thinks they fixed the problem
already the the the scientist just rolls
their eyes and exasperation and tells
them exactly what's wrong and video and
so
it's a conceptual disconnect even though
the language is well understood by both
parties and it's it's very fascinating
and it really gets to the point of
exactly what you see when you see a
meeting of software engineers and
computational scientists so so
scientific programming really where the
software engineer really has to start
thinking about this a little bit is it's
all about the science that's what they
think about or the engineering if you're
talking about the running of a crash
code or a tidal surge program to see
what's going to happen in the you know
as a pair of category four hurricane
comes up the Mississippi River Valley
and so on and so forth scientific and
engineering codes are expensive codes
live a long time partially because the
verification and validation strategy of
energy coat any code is a very long time
performance really matters the value
almost always of these codes they're
pushed to the limit of the computational
science for instance current weather
prediction models would love to be able
to hit the tornadoes and and other
violent storm events that occur in the
mid western part of the United States it
turns out there just isn't enough
computational ability to give enough
resolution to look for the formations of
certain micro storms it just is not and
that's you know and that's trust me it's
been years of research and adaptive
grids grab the adaptive time models so
on and so forth it's a real issue and
will continue to be a real issue it's
also for high-energy physics there's
another whole set of problems in that as
well hardware platforms change often
think about the case where the hardware
changes two or three times in the
development cycle of your software
rather than the other way around okay it
gives a whole different set of project
management problems and portability
problems and so on and so forth it's all
Fortran 77 and c plus plus plus that's
that's what it is and and this is
partially because of the legacy codes in
fact this is very true of five
ESS and very true of any large legacy
software system that lives a long time
the tools get frozen in so the ability
to do abstraction automation in any
productivity that's associated with
building or modifying or evolving that
software gets frozen in at the time
those tools are originally decided
because I I basically ended up trying to
put C++ in five ESS I actually did some
experiments on five us and it was the
most difficult thing because it was like
you know first you had to get the rut
you know the runtime environments right
then you had to get the debugging tools
right then you had to get the automated
libraries that brought in the pieces
that had changed I mean it just one it
was one thing after another and you
could spend years working out all the
problems hardware costs dominate and
portability really matters if you're
going through several generations of
hardware in the course of the
development of the software application
portability is a big big issue okay yeah
why so so well I agree that that you
know the codes can live 10 13 years and
so the hardware platform attractive
running home will change our thought
patterns in the class of the hardware
definitely changed we had better machine
fridge you know about 15 years now we've
had cluster machine for about 13 years
so that so that so the general class
machine and therefore the way you have a
program or write the programs you know
previously with special convector tight
loops and now it's all about you know
communication yeah and data distribution
now that doesn't really change so you
know I would quibble there about the
saints the really good platform change
we've had message passing distributed
memory codes for about 15 years yeah
yeah and then the hardware costs
dominating um you know I mean sure a
supercomputing called your cost about a
hundred million dollars and it's ball
maybe once every 3-4 years but the
programming costs at the National Labs I
mean each of the budgets there is about
a billion dollars per year how three of
them so you know if you prepare you know
three billion dollar personnel cars per
year vs 100 million dollar re on cause
there's four years so let me let me let
me let me let me abstract two of the
things because we could end up spending
the rest of time discussing the two
points you brought up the first point
was is that the you know the style of
supercomputer machines hasn't really
changed and actually their architecture
is relatively similar and there are a
lot there are a lot of things around
that that have allowed some amount of
abstraction and automation to be
developed and therefore some
productivity and I agree with that it's
a gets a bit more complicated because
different applications do different
things and we can talk we can talk about
that offline the second comment has to
do help me out what was it was the
hardware hardware costs dominate it's a
perfect observation and one that is very
social science and political oriented
and not technological oriented in its
sense that the national budgets of the
National Labs is very very diffusely
connected with the acquisition process
of these systems and everything in other
words all have to be approved by
Congress and and so and those there's
influences their that create don't allow
for direct feedback loops of improving
productivity but with the machine design
and a perfect example is the new
technologies and that really need to be
done on machines that are petascale
where you have a hundred thousand
processors you have to start talking
about virtualization runtime
virtualization you have to start talking
about the machine has to be able to keep
track of of itself in the sense that of
a switching system which could always
tell if it was partially broken or not
the technology has not come into normal
computing play in general except very
recently in certain types of networking
things and stuff but both a ver
very good comments but let me give you
the idea first off 35 years this this is
we went in and studied several of the
DoD do e benchmark codes that are used
for all kinds of things modeling of the
deterioration of materials in a holding
radioactive waste so on and so forth and
bottom line is is basically ten years is
about the development cycle of these
things okay and in fact right now this
is the current projected profile of the
Falcon which is a new code I won't say
what it does because it's a DoD code but
in essence this is its model and this is
and this model is based on historical
what they do with other codes okay so
initial development typically takes five
years serious testing by customers is
another five years you then get into
this maintenance and and an evolution
kind of cycle from 10 to 25 years which
is 15 years of real useful stuff and
then 25 to 35 years you get into a
retirement face but you're in essence
for 25 years you're getting useful
results out of these codes and so that's
that's the given so part of the problem
is the software engineers haven't seen
this online transaction processing with
kicks and so on and so forth didn't last
this long it's been completely replaced
with Java and some and other runtime
environments and transaction processing
systems okay that's that's the problem
and why is that partially because in the
scientist the verification and
validation problem is a tough one making
sure that the code is really doing the
right thing and doing it correctly and
by the way this is much more reminiscent
of what five ESS looks like which
started about 1978 and is still being
sold by loosen alcatel technologies
today which is 1982 is the first ship so
we're at night 2008 so 25 26 years so I
mean so we're just about probably at
this part and Luke 5 ESS was probably
the most successful digital switch
anyway let me
on the productivity gridlock then is a
programming so we're still peeling away
this onion we sort of see these things
some of the assumptions don't match what
software engineers are doing but in
essence what we actually ended up doing
is going in and fig watching and
observing scientists doing their work
and engineers actually using crash codes
and other things to see what they were
doing and the programming workflow has
some bottlenecks in it developing the
scientific programs the serial
optimization and tuning the code
paralyzation and optimization and the
porting and these really turn out to
have two fundamental things the manual
programming effort in other words we
still haven't gotten enough automation
in here and the expertise and let me say
a little bit more now I want to talk
about I'm going to come back to that in
a minute but I want to talk about how we
investigated this for the lat 45 the
five years we were working on the
problem what we did is embrace the
broadest possible view of productivity
including all the human task skills
motivations organizations and cultures
therefore your question about the
National Labs having a 1 billion dollar
software engineering budget and only
buying 1 million 100 million dollar
machines is a pretty valid model the
problem is is that it fits in an
organization in a set of cultures that
don't create the feedback loops that are
needed for evolution of the general
system put the investigation the sound
as possible scientific base drawing
above physical and social scientists
methods and this results in a three
stage research framework which we found
very useful so the stages are explore
and discover test and define and
evaluate and validate and the goals are
developed hypotheses test and refine
models replicate and validate findings
okay and we use a series of methods
qualitative qualitative and quantitative
and quantitative and so we go the whole
spectrum from everywhere from grounded
theory all the way to quasi-experimental
designs where we try to be go through a
more of a biological metaphor of an in
vitro in vivo it's a lot like what
happens in software engineering now if
you're a tool builder and you so you
have hypothesis that
fighting this automated extraction and
automation the abstraction offered by
the tool the automation offered by the
execution of that tool it's going to
improve productivity you don't first go
and try to sell a Microsoft invincible
what you do is you actually work on the
tool and you develop in vitro in other
words outside of the main development
lines and everything else the fact that
it works and everything and then
eventually you have an adoption strategy
and you move it in and in a rational way
and in essence that's sort of a
biological metaphor you start with an in
vitro version and you move to in vivo
and that's and you keep it try to keep
it quantitative and sometimes you use
qualitative methods because your
experimental designs assume certain
things and sometimes those or
assumptions are wrong and therefore you
then you have to go back so this isn't a
straight line process as much as it's
often iterative in its nature and I
already mentioned that so let me go
through this a little bit so what we
there are two major workflows that you
see in in scientific computing that are
troublesome the first one is the
scientist or set of scientists building
the original code and doing the science
programming or investigating the science
so they're on this continual very rapid
evolution kind of thing of their
application the other phase is where you
end up having a code like a crash code
and now you're just going to crash the
automobile but now you want to do
different automobiles and now you want
to do different crash situations and so
consequently the basic finite element
model and metal deformations and all
that stuff is pretty much done what you
really need to do is just change the
databases and everything so one is like
developing the codes and the other is
really running the codes in a very high
low if you let me just say that so and
we tried to capture this a little bit
and so which it but what this is the
general model meaning that also includes
developing the code originally and what
you discover is that not only do you
need domain scientist you also need
people who really know how to write
software and then you need people who
really know how to manage and
maintain and evolve software and then
you need to know have to have people who
know how to take an application and
actually tune it there's a lot of
different very highly specialized skills
hear that so therefore distinct skill
sets the main science the scientific
computing just mapping it on to a
cluster and understanding the
reliability performance characteristics
of a cluster and how you might want to
organize your application on them is
kind of an interesting set of challenges
the scaling is also another piece so how
do I get that and then the management so
the skills are useful when they are
synchronized through communication
collaboration or exists in one person
and I love this what you observe of
course is the teams that have good
communication protocols and everything
and work together as a team can do this
a lot better than a group that are very
disjoint and so on and so forth and even
works best when you put the skills all
in one person because then we only have
to apply the fact that the person seinen
and and and well we made an assumption
there but the reality is is that what
you find out is still to skill sets are
rare think of think of somebody who is
at the lead in scientific computing and
also in the domain science at the same
time okay and writing in both literature
bodies just go and look at people who
are there okay three skill sets are very
rare and four is like a moon rock okay
that's it and so that in essence is the
problem so and and the reality is is if
you think about the social institutional
evolution of like the labs the the DoD
labs the Department of Defense labs the
Department of Energy labs and so on and
so forth it's not one that really lends
itself to great teamwork kinds of things
although that's what's been asked of a
lot of them okay so uh so so if I if if
you had to say it in a nutshell what is
the productivity gridlock the
productivity gridlock really comes about
because of the need for very very highly
specialized sets of skills being very
very tightly coordinated and
orchestrated to maintain and evolve
either the software or to apply it to
different situations and run it for
different cases and and almost always
because these machines the clusters that
we talked about the the message passing
so much of that stuff depends on the
nature of the geometries of problems for
instance and finite element modeling and
so on and so forth that it's not just a
simple reapplication it's almost
sometimes the whole retuning of the
application has to happen if you're
going to change for instance the way the
car crashes you might want to take
instead of doing car crashes think about
just crashing 24-foot motorboats same
kind of holes and I'm a water now but
you can start seeing me it's a complete
redo of everything because of of a lot
of different pieces of the application
although a lot of the finite element and
the basic science is all the same so let
me talk about so one other thing that we
discovered is it's really kind of tragic
and what's going on is that the
scientists have tool complaints and the
reality is is that the productivity on
being able to either evolve and maintain
an application or to run it and other
things are those abstractions and
automations which is sort of the but
bread and butter of software engineering
aren't essence encapsulated in tools and
what we have in scientific community is
tools that are hard to learn they don't
scale differ across platforms poorly
supported in too expensive and in
essence what we're looking at is
probably to certain extent the
scientists not understanding nor the
phenomena being understood that once you
use those tools to develop your initial
application they became frozen in and
the productivity proposition of those
tools actually is frozen into that
application forever basically and then
you have to
develop a business model that maintains
those tools for 35 years that's what how
long it took or at least have a
maintenance and evolution strategy for
them and what you see where does this
come and get you its general computing I
and so what what what the software
engineer doesn't see perhaps is that in
in some fundamental sense the 35 years
is a big deal okay and that general
computing IDEs and have different
assumptions lifetime with codes show
evolution you know slows evolution of
tools the field is small and specialized
so from the current business models
that's a really bad thing because
there's no scale involved so
consequently these things are very very
expensive to build and investment in
tools is insufficient another important
thing is um this is really true of when
we were studying some clusters and
people were using different Intel
processors and then they ran over and
we're using AMD processors and there
were a set of compilers that were being
made available by Intel research that
we're doing some very very nice elegant
kinds of parallelization detection and
so on and so forth and in old fortran 77
codes and Fortran and C++ goes and they
actually got removed from the market
because they didn't they were actually
being maintained by Intel research and
they decided they weren't going to go
that way architectural II so they just
wanted to take them off so I mean
sometimes even these things for business
reasons get moved removed and since they
weren't part of the open group community
it cause like a really great problem in
how clusters were being used for certain
types of computational science
computations so this is revisiting that
early point I made about the science
coming out wrong because the computation
really wasn't valid okay and and and
really comes down to here's what the
issue really is and scientists have to
think about this a lot harder trust in
the validity of the computational
outcomes the key product is a key
productivity issue because if it's wrong
you got no productivity okay the value
is zero okay and you get a spent
whatever you spent
how do scientists build confidence in
their codes they look right things these
are real comments when you go and ask
the scientist about it four or five
years to get some confidence in the code
that you know in other words they run it
on a lot of different problems they can
figure out and everything and then you
know you sort of what you find out of
course is that the domain scientists the
really good domain scientists haven't a
set of ideas about the verification and
validation sequence because they
understand the weaknesses of
computational strategies and so they
even have some ideas about how to do
this but no way is that codified or
shared in the community so not even
common knowledge like that gets shared
oh and this this comment was really
great I it's sort of an inverse flip we
were talking to some people about well
what happened when you abandon this code
entry was one guy was when I was
actually a woman scientist she was very
upset because she had just finally
gotten to understand and had some
confidence in the code and they decided
not to fund it anymore so it was down
the you know and now she had to start
out beginning again which was pretty it
was very hard so the point here is the
problem is is that you always have to be
careful about this just like you do in
any experimental methodology but it's an
area where I think scientists have to
innovate and they manage threats to
validity meaning the interpretation of a
particular experiment they just have to
get there and works needed here so so
breaking the gridlock and software
engineering so the answer is is it's not
like software engineering can say here
take two of these and come back and see
me in a week okay the reality is is that
the two communities have to work
together okay and they have to sort of
close that gap in communications that
has grown up between the two of them and
in some sense software engineering has a
general paradigm of automation
abstraction and measurement to introduce
the and the scientific programming
community has to start thinking about
investment and modernization okay and
there are some common things that they
have to work on together like how best
to use computers to help with the
verification and validation
program let me give you a little
anecdotal story about how 5 ESS used to
do it we built computers to generate
load on a 5 ESS machine we had switches
that basically did nothing but make
telephone calls on a 5 ESS machine so we
could test it okay well you know that's
kind of it that now that's one way of
doing it it's not the only way of doing
it but those are the kinds of things
that you have to start thinking about if
you're if it means because after all
there's no productivity proposition if
the results are incorrect so okay so let
me let me talk about some empirical
studies I like doing empirical studies
I'm empiricist at heart so comfy I put
up these two myths and I wanted to be a
little bit controversial and I'll tell
you what the experiments were and so on
and so forth so what we did was in the
computational science arena we actually
identified some domain scientists who
were building computational codes for
for a plasma fusion machine for toroid
Xin fact we we have myself being a
high-energy physicist Eugene lo who is
one of the other collaborators here
Eugene is a has his PhD and
computational physics from Caltech and
and and so Eugene actually went and
became a scientist to the person at
Princeton Plasma laboratories who wrote
the code when and I've not even sure I'm
going to say G kinetic whatever but
anyway it models the energy loss
mechanism and a tokamak and so what
Eugene undertook to do after he did the
nasty ll benchmarks is he wanted to go
and see if he could rewrite the code to
be more expressive and have much more
productive and so we actually went in
and started doing some of this we also
had another scientist who was doing the
electrostatic potential and cones the
net out was is that we were able to
improve productivity by about a factor
10 and i'll explain that experiment a
little bit another computer science myth
is the the prescription of implements
serial and parallel
for multicore and clusters experiments
with programming teams indicate this is
the wrong strategy sub optimal solutions
are achieved okay we've done a Walter
tisha at the University of Karlsruhe has
actually started doing experiments on
this and in the international conference
on software engineering there was a
workshop before the conference on
multi-core systems and Walter showed me
some of the results of some of the
initial experiments and it certainly
indicates that the teams that achieve
the best parallelization got the best
running code with the fewest defects and
so on and so forth were the ones who
tried directly to go to a meet to the
parallel implementation apparently the
serialized version creates certain
barriers because now it works and it
works good enough so you don't actually
go back and redo certain things so you
make these engineering trade-off so you
end up with a mixture of serial and
parallel and it's kind of fascinating
but it's a it's not past the scope of
this but it's an interesting kind of
investigation that software engineering
can do to get to the heart of this and
which is actually one that I think is
kind of fun so what we did was looked at
the nasty LOL benchmarks and port the f
77 version to a more modern fortran 90
version we did these four things the
result we reduced the source code by
about a factor 10 because we reduce the
source code by a factor 10 we inferred
that we reduce the cost by about a
factor 10 since any of the kokomo cost
models or anything for software
development off basically or linearly
related to the size of the software and
in these scales so what we and and
something else surprising happen here's
a here's a one of the mavs parallel
benchmarks known as parallels benchmarks
take some of the more successful
computational fluid dynamics codes or
other kernels of the application and
uses them to benchmark different
architectures and so on and so forth and
they're all written in Fortran 77 and
then they also have a specification and
they talk about some type of iterative
methods to solve things using
multi-process multi computers and they
have MP
I implementations and so and so forth
but what scientists have been trying to
do is obviously even keep that at a low
level and just give you a more a cleaner
representation here's a fortran 90 high
productivity version of this the reality
is is that the point being is that
Fortran 77 and and you saw earlier is
that if you go on look at the navs PLL
benchmark for fortran 77 you see a lot
of configuration testing machine testing
there are a lot of non-portable elements
in it that have been sort of if then
else out by testing certain machine
configurations but the bottom line is is
that this is much harder to understand
and match to this specification than
something like this and the reality is
is that what software engineering knew
already was that representation is a big
deal and not read translating the
specifications over and over again is
another big deal in other words matching
the actual representation that gets
compiled to the formal representation
and this is sort of work that parness
has done over many years and many other
you know John Gannon dink was the one
who did the thing just about simple
comments in the mid-70s but that the
bottom line is is that you can see that
not only is the code much more compact
and clearer but that at some point I
don't have to worry about the
verification validation problem I have
to prove that my compilers do the right
things but I don't have to show you know
but just by general inspection I can I
can reach the conclusion that I've
implemented what the specification asked
okay so concluding remarks well of
course yes is the answer and
computational scientists need to realize
that their greatest strengths maybe the
greatest barriers to improvement and
software engineers need to rethink some
of their solutions and the two
communities have to work together and
that's really the bottom line of the
talk and hopefully I wanted to mention
some of my collaborators I said some the
co-authors on this paper which was
written for the just the the I Triple E
software magazine that was just out this
month i think is that and of course we
didn't get it except it was that it was
Stewart fog oops Stewart Falk and Susan
Squires and Michael vana vana Susan
michael and i formed the productivity
team at sun and then Tom Nash is a
physicist Doug post is in is a high as a
plasma physicist Walter is that the
university of karlsruhe Eugene low
Declan Murphy Chris Vic and allen wood
or at Sun Microsystems still and all
were involved in the productivity work
and some of the some of this and I I you
can actually go and look up a lot of
these a lot of the individual results
are written up and I would prefer rather
than deep diving into one I just wanted
to sort of give an overview because to
me there's two important elements this
research the composition to see the
whole to answer a big significant
question the second is is how do you do
little studies in that framework to
actually help yourself and understand
make sure you're understanding is
correct so the bibliography talks about
some of those important studies and case
studies we did the the different
communities that get involved in this
kind of stuff I think I gave a pointer
to Walters paper on multi-core
programming if people are interested in
looking at that and and and that's
actually a very new result that's a
result this year but it is something
that occurred to us to ask the question
a few years ago is that the right
prescription do the serial version and
then rewrite it for parallel and it
doesn't look like it is the best
solution to the problem and I mean see
was there anything else I have now
that's it and questions